my guest today may be one of the best uh
stories out there for a man who chose to
change his life
and it dramatically helped him out he
went from i think spending 15 years in
jail and expelling to
selling his bread company which i've
never had i'm gonna have it today live
dave's killer bread for 275 million
dollars
cash and uh he hires
ex felons ex men who did time
i think a third of their employees are
ex-felons with that being said my guest
today is dave dahl dave thank you so
much
for being a guest on valuetainment yeah
my pleasure so if first of all i read
this story i watch all your videos you
know how open you are
about things you've done it's not like
you're even hiding it you just kind of
openly share here's what i did here's
what i did there this is who i was so
if you don't mind taking a minute here
and sharing with the audience
you know your your background story or
how you went from where you were at to
start the company i think that'd be
great for starters
i had a pretty screwed up childhood the
kind of childhood that nobody
you know i can't even explain to someone
and have them
understand uh but it is what it is
and you know i was a baker my dad was a
baker
um that's what we did when we were when
we were kids growing up we didn't have
money but we managed to
get by with uh you know
producing bread you know i didn't want
to do that i had a lot of depression
when i was young and i turned to drugs
and eventually crime was really the only
thing i knew how to do besides bread and
i didn't really know how to do that
either
uh the the crime part so i had to learn
the hard way and
that's why i went to prison four times i
was not very good at it
so i did 15 years
all drug related in the sense that
everything was in order to get drugs
and uh so four trips to prison my
fourth time down i had the epiphany
uh i i got some help for my medicaid i
got some medication from my
for my uh um depression
and it actually worked for me and then i
went to school for drafting computer
computer
drafting which is a trade that was
exciting to me
i had a lot of fun with it and i
realized i was capable of doing more
than i thought
so uh i excelled at that
and eventually got out of prison
and went to work making bread and you
know work with my family
and creating my own products so
i didn't expect the kind of success that
i had but i
um i mean nobody could right and bread
but
i i had a lot of fun just
trying to make something happen i used
the same principles that i learned in
drafting the same
mental principles i was able to design
six varieties of bread which i took to
the farmer's market
the same year that i got out of prison
so and and how was it received when you
took it to the farmers market
it was like a dream you know you could
never imagine
you know i i know i went there i
remember
people coming up and trying it walking
away
and then coming back with six more
people you know
it was that kind of thing and uh
it got so so busy we were the most
popular
thing at the market really the portland
farmers market
and uh so word of mouth immediately
began
you know became our our marketing tool
the more you got the bread in somebody's
mouth the more the more you sold
it when did the company get started was
it in 2013 that it got started or
when did it when did it get started no
uh started in 2005. now my dad
started the company in 1955
but when i got out of prison it was 2005
and that's when dave's killer bread
started got it so 2005 is when that got
started so
and and dave your your background in
business
you know i know you and your brother
were running together as well
were you more on the marketing side were
you on the selling side were you on the
product development side
what was your strength to go from not
having any background to building a
company where somebody cuts you check
for 275.
that's a good question uh fortunately
you know i had an infrastructure in a
sense to start with i got out
and there was already uh a way to make a
product
uh to produce a product at a small
we weren't able to produce a lot of
product but we were able to put
to keep keep up with demands for a
little while
and uh so the thing was it gave me a
chance i got out of work
got out of prison went to work for 12
bucks an hour
the same time i was moonlighting as a
product developer
so i created these products like i said
using
the same principles i learned in
drafting i was never
so much the guy that did finances or
um you know the bean counting and all
that kind of stuff but the money was
never really
that important to me i just wanted to
make a living
and so i i just was
i got excited about the development of
the product and then
the the marketing of the product
essentially i was a product developer
and a marketer but the marketer the
marketing aspect was
it took over they took over everything
david 05 how big was the business if you
were to say like your dad's uh
was it one shop was it one store how big
was the business in o5
my dad's business and which was taken
over by my brother
when uh at the time that i
came out of prison i think there was
around 30 employees
and so it was a business it was a
wholesale bakery that was
basically mostly producing private label
products in order to keep going
they were making i think the the most
the biggest account and the the best
account at that time was trader joe's
so we were producing our products for
other people
and we also made had a a brand called
nature bank
that my brother had been keeping alive
for a few years got it and and by the
time you guys ended up selling it can
you give us some
stats like hey this is how many breads
we sold today this is how many we made
every day this is how many employees we
have
to go from all five to the point you got
sold it
well okay uh well we were producing the
nature bake and the private label
products
at the same time that i was beginning
this
uh dave's killer brad project it's at
the time it was just a project it was
like
more more bread for the company didn't
realize it would eventually take over
so at that time it was like yo we made a
couple hundred dollars a week
to take to the farmer's market and we
were selling out
really well we were we were everything
was a was an experiment
everything you know marketing experiment
um
you know production experiment or you
know testing
different things in the product which
was my my main focus
was making sure the bread was perfect so
you know i was like 200 loaves in 2000
early 2000 or like august of 2005.
uh by the next year
by early in the next year we were like 6
000 a week
and then the year after that i mean i i
couldn't even give you the numbers
it was it it multiplied by
you know double digits as far as uh
if if you had like if you sold 20 000
one year then the next year was a
hundred thousand and the next year was
500 000 and you know or that kind of
thing
and uh i mean it was it was growing at
an incredible rate the kind of rate was
really hard to keep up with
and the challenges were we're more about
like how we're going to finance this
next growth spurt
you know we got to get we got to get
people that are going to back us up
because we don't have that money you
know you can't
that's one of the biggest challenges you
have as a growing businessman and
who makes stuff make stuff produces
stuff from you know goods
rather than just say software or
something that
uh you sell an idea is one thing but
actually having to produce it
uh coming up with the ingredients see
all the logistics of that
as we were growing thankfully my brother
and my nephew who were my partners
were more into the logistical side of
getting the ingredients
and uh dealing with all the challenges
that we had
of producing the product how many is it
selling right now do you have any idea
because you're saying from
five 6 k do you have any idea how many
it's selling right now per week
and it's it's impossible to say because
i'm not involved anymore
but i can say that when i left
we were in probably
seven states western states
and a few little outposts away from
there
um we were selling we were producing
uh about a half million lowers a week a
little bit more
at that time and uh that was tough you
know just
keeping up so we had other people we had
safeway bakeries
and such making our product trying to
trying to make our product it was
it was hard to get their culture to keep
up with ours
uh in the way that we looked at making
the bread
that's one of another one of the
challenges that you have so we were
where were we at uh like i said half a
million loaves a week probably more than
that when i left
i it's got to be more like 10 million
now
you know more than that even i don't
know because you think
the way i see it growing it's now made
in
entirely it's made in canada it's made
in several places in the u.s
it's made in mexico it's all over the
place
that's a that's amazing to see now uh
for you i got
i got a few different questions for you
one i have
you and your relationship with your
father because i got two boys i got a
girl and i just had a newborn
two or three weeks ago so i got four
kids i want to know where that conflict
was with your pops
then the business side then how do you
manage ex-cons who don't like to follow
the rules like
there's got to be a way of leading that
there's got to be some interesting way
of leading them
but let's first go to a father-son
relationship
dave was it more you think was it more
uh
he think was it more an environment
thing or was it more a combination of
everything that there was a division
like you know a bit of a rift between
you and your pops
i didn't like the way my my father was i
i didn't like the way i was i i didn't
grow up with much self-esteem and i
don't think my dad had a lot of
self-esteem
i think that the things that the same
things that make you laugh can make you
cry
in the sense that my dad was a
hard-working you know creative uh
guy his focus was on his business
and that rubbed off on me
obviously but at the time i just looked
at him as this
this really rough character without a
whole lot of gray social graces or
anything he wasn't teaching me any
things i wanted to learn
and eventually i learned some of the
things anyway
and he was very stern
and he's just a hard guy to get along
with
and that was kind of the way i saw it
growing up
and i just felt like crap you know that
was the conflict i
it wasn't until way later that i began
to realize it was after he was
he had passed that i realized he was
actually a very
uh interesting and
uh interesting guy who deserved a lot of
credit especially
when you consider dave stiller bread
would never have happened without him
that's it's interesting you've been able
to give that uh credit to him
did you did your brother also have
conflicts with him as well or was it
more you than him
i think my brother had even more
conflicts because my brother was
eight years older than me and he grew up
he was my boss
when i was you know growing up my
brother was far different from my dad he
wasn't
nearly the hard guy the mean guy
whatever and they would fight you know
a lot bump heads because
they just had different ways of trying
to get the work done
and trying to account for things trying
to do accounting bookkeeping
um my dad just had a very rough way
about it
my brother wanted to streamline the
process and make it work better
got it did your parents stay married
were they together
my parents stayed married uh until my
dad died in 1998.
wow so props to your mom to to to be in
that environment and you know uh
was she the one was she somebody that
was more the one that gave you love give
your brother-in-law
yeah she was a loving person a kind very
kind person
religious person
and she
she had all of her own um struggles with
you know uh self-esteem and all that we
all did
but she was very kind about it she just
had a different approach
about how she dealt with people she was
very uh
humble and i think i learned humility
from her eventually
well that's that's the the great part
about how the man upstairs created a mom
and a dad for us to kind of get a little
bit of balance from
both sides was your dad ever in the
military or was did he have a military
background yeah
my dad was in the uh in world war ii
uh from right about the time that it
started to the time that
he was at four years from 41 to 45
as a navy he was a cook on a ship
my dad always wanted to be a baker so i
think that's what he was was a baker on
the ship
yeah you know they say a lot of the uh
folks who come from the great depression
era
their level of understanding of the next
generation is so much
harder for them because they had it so
hard like do you really and they're so
afraid
of losing everything because you know
how it was in the 30s
so it's tough for us to embrace them and
understand them sometimes and
it's tough for them to communicate uh
with us my dad
is one of the toughest guys man like
nothing was ever
at a standard but you know 79 years old
today he still lives with me
but uh he was able to see the changes
taking place
and i'm sure if he was watching right
now watching over you guys he's probably
blown away by what you and your
brother have been able to build as a
company and probably even more than that
how was it for you and your brother
working together did you guys get along
did you have conflicts or was it just
easy to
work together yeah it was it was uh
almost either one of us were murderers
right but if we were somebody's probably
dead right now and then there was
my nephew as well so i always felt like
it was my brother and my nephew against
me
so uh but i i knew i had
something i knew i believed in what i
was doing
and so a lot of times
knowing what i wanted and going to get
it sometimes
uh they didn't agree
and so we had to get through that it was
tough
got it i mean you know to think about
this you know
uh you're saying 10 a week if they're
saying 10 million a week
that's you want it right i mean that's
literally you on the on the back
right yeah yeah yeah there's a good
story about uh
the creation of that logo i'll try i
just real real quick i
i didn't have any money remember you
know i mean we didn't have a budget for
creating dave's killer bread it was kind
of like you're going to have to make
this
[Music]
you know on a shoestring so i found an
artist
i had an idea you know from talking to a
copyright attorney
i got this idea of making a logo
and so i drew up real quick i drew a
logo
idea of this guy it was way too
complicated
for a logo but it was this guy who
represented me
holding his guitar standing in front
standing in front of this wall
and on this brick wall was big letters
dave's bread
and then somebody comes along with a
spray can
a red spray paint can and and
you know tags killer on on that yeah
that doesn't that doesn't you can't tell
that by looking at the logo
but that was my idea and then i got a
guy i paid him
uh i didn't have much money i don't
remember what i ended up paying it was
like
two or three hundred bucks i believe and
he tried he kept he kept trying to he
was a cartoonist and he kept trying to
uh
make me look almost like me you know i'm
like no dude you gotta
you gotta make me look better you know
better better better and i i finally
you know the last thing i got to do was
to make my arms ridiculously big
yeah i said look i'm i'm paying you the
big bucks make my arms big
by the way is this the original original
logo
yeah that's never really changed no oh
and i know you play guitar so now for
some people that don't know when you do
15 years in prison and you
name your bread dave's killer bread i
mean you know immediately people go
to a different place when they see
dave's killer bread yeah can you please
clarify that particular
adjective yeah there's sometimes people
uh they assume
uh some certain people's brains work
that way right where it's immediately
like
they go with they go straight to oh
prison
killer okay he's a killer from prison
right no
and so i never even thought of that i
just was always wanted to make a loaf of
bread called killer bread
and eventually i just made this loaf of
bread called killer bread and next thing
you know all my breads being called
dave's killer bread so uh
that's it it just took off so it says
five grams of protein
five grams of fiber 260 milligrams of
omega-3 22 grams of whole grain
i've never had this before okay but i'm
gonna try it right now and
my employees swear by this it's in the
fridge
every day they eat this
now what you should be noticing right
now is really good mouth feel
and really good flavor oh my gosh
that's that's 21 whole grains that
you're eating right now
21 whole grains and seeds my favorite is
good seed i
even have it on the back of my you know
tattoo of it on my back
but uh good seed
you know i always named my breads i
named my breads before i created them
you know uh so i was like you know
good seed was about my transformation
from being a bad seed to a good seed and
so i named i created a bread named good
seed
around the name i love that by the way
just so everybody knows you're not
paying me to do this there is no
sponsorship here
he does you don't even own the company
anymore so why would you pay me to do
this
i'm just it doesn't even benefit him by
me saying the spread is good what did i
say the bread sucks or it's great he
doesn't make a penny more penny less
i think yeah you can tell the truth yeah
but no this thing
is so so we talked about pops we talked
about the business side
um i still can't i mean even my camera
guys right in oscar's uh
amazed by the taste of it uh managing
former felons right folks who did time
you got a third of your employees at the
time when you guys sold the company
out of your 300 employees near nearly a
hundred
had done time before one how did you
find them did they find you or you found
them and two how did you hold them
accountable
well that's a that's a big one right
there
uh the thing was we
started you know remember we're we're
growing really fast so you're hiring
really fast which is
you know can be challenging trying to
get the right people
and myself the thing that i
understood better than a lot of people
would understand is that
ex-felons can be great assets
you know anybody who's given a chance
when they've when they've hit a bottom
say can can they can be grateful
and hard-working employees and so
that was something we instinctively sort
of knew because of my own uh
experience the thing was we
were willing to give those guys and
ladies challenge chances
that a lot of people wouldn't give them
and
and so they were grateful to that but we
also
made a lot of mistakes in the beginning
and hired the wrong people
it's really about getting the right
people and of course like you say
treating them right and holding them
accountable to the best of your ability
we had a strong vision for the product
that we
wanted to make and by that time we also
had
my story you know so people actually
searched
ex felons would actually search out our
company to come work for us
so but but we help people to a certain
standard that i would say that i
sort of emulated or that i uh
was the progenitor of i
it's like okay you gotta i'm expecting
you
to follow in my footsteps and so it once
they get out of that line they tend to
go a different direction and they don't
make it it's like
it's a little bit of humility which is
for a next felon is not an easy thing
because most
you go to present most of you most of
your life you
uh you do crime you gotta have i
tend to have a bad answer and
these guys these were mostly people who
were trying to turn over a new leap so
we were just
we just had to hold them to that
standard and and
were you mainly looking for a person
that maybe wants a major change and they
have a positive attitude because you
could build on the attitude because you
said
even if you're hiring former inmates you
could still hire the wrong
former inmates right former so so how
did you especially when you're hiring
fast
that's right really quickly how do you
differentiate between the two
uh well for me okay that's a good
question
like i wonder like your interview
process did you ask me three questions
or two questions that was
gave you an idea to say this is a person
we ought to give an opportunity to
absolutely uh that was my approach
it was not easy to always get that
approach
used when interviewing folks because
they weren't
uh i wasn't always the one doing the
interviewing in those early days
uh but my intention
for those was always like okay what have
you been doing
the last few years you've been in prison
right okay
you want to just say if somebody just
goes well yeah i've been in prison for
the last few years so you know
well there's an opportunity wherever
you're at to work on yourself
so what have you been doing during that
time to help yourself
and to maybe help your family you know
just to be a better person and
that isn't just that question alone
that question and follow-up questions on
that
can get people uh you can find out what
a person's about
how do you may not be right every time
yeah that's true you're not going to be
right every time
yeah that is true how did you work on
yourself i know there's a part of it
where
in many interviews you talk about the
fact that the you know
proper medication helped and you know
proper sitting down with the doctor help
but but it's got to be even more than
that like what else was it for you
that you said did you read books did you
have affirmations did you have
an inspiration from a movie from an
article from
a star from somebody we know where did
you grab your source of inspiration from
i was always searching even in the first
three
times i did my i went to prison the
fourth time
i i really thought well my life was over
i was like it's over
there's nothing i'm going to be able to
do to get out you know this
this is the person that i've i have
chosen to be and now i'm a wreck and
you know and so i had this really
negative attitude but i also
was trying because i didn't have any
choice but to try to figure something
out
but every night was was a struggle for
me
and every day to get up and even go to
ciao or go
go out to the yard and do whatever i was
doing
uh i didn't want to face the day you
know that's how bad i felt
and so it i had to
put on an air of of strength even though
i felt
like inside i felt like a mass of jelly
you know i felt terrible
and so um that was a terrible thing to
not really be able to be myself
because i i didn't like myself so
what happened was in 2001
i let down my guard if you will i
dropped a piece of paper and we call it
a type and it's just a piece of
a piece of paper where you ask for
whatever
you know from from the uh
from the authorities and i had decided
after a few years in prison that time
that i needed some help and that i would
ask for help and that was a big deal for
me
nobody wants to ask for help in prison
you know they want to be tough they want
to be
cool they want to be hard but it was the
best thing that i ever did i asked for
help i put the kite in
i got meds which i didn't think would
help me
but they really made a big difference to
me because
i was almost sudden able to focus
because i i wasn't thinking
depressed negative thoughts all the time
you know this all went the same time i
was
studying things like buddhism buddhist
principles you know other
like you say affirmations i i was
reading books to try to help me
be a better person but it never worked
until i took that medication
and i asked for help and then i went to
school for drafting
about it was in the next few months i
started going to school
and uh the combination of all those
things
made me realize i wasn't the guy that i
had always thought it was i didn't have
to be that guy
and so that was a pretty amazing moment
in my life and
and from that point on no matter how
many times i still screwed up
i always knew i was going to be okay
and i knew i could work hard work hard
and make something happen
very very uh a great story to hear now
let me ask you for yourself is it a
challenge till today because i do know i
think in 2014 something happened with an
escalade driving into the car
is it a challenge that you struggle with
till today is it still constant working
on it
yeah you got to work on for me it's the
substance abuse just that
you know i've always you're always that
far away from
you know getting gobbled up by the
monster which is
to me it could be depression or if that
happened again that
you know any kind of thing where that
took me off course mentally would be
bad uh but i don't feel that that is a
problem anymore
because of all the the time i've got of
doing
doing good good stuff uh but i did and
to
you know 2013 i had uh
i had been i had become very successful
and
i started kind of packing myself on the
back a lot even though
i didn't i didn't want to do that i
didn't i didn't believe that i didn't
want to think of myself as a rock star
i just wanted to be this guy to continue
to be this guy
but i had started drinking you know
celebrating
i was going to mexico i discovered
tequila
you know and i started having a great
time and
uh you know for me i don't really do
anything a little bit i do
i do it a lot you can look at my you can
look at the
mask behind me that's like that's like a
that's like a needle in the haystack of
the stuff that i had
but anyway you're one of the biggest
collectors in the world apparently i
mean it's uh
you you gotta grab it yeah i gotta be
one of
one of the most prolific uh
african art collectors that there is but
anyway
that's that's either cool or that's kind
of insane one of the other i go
so uh but like that's another thing i
mean
this this arc was one of the things that
brought me out of what happened in 2013
with the escalade and the three cop cars
uh
and and but the reason that that
happened uh
there's not a simple reason but uh was
because of that
getting away from who i was you know
becoming
i always was afraid of becoming a parody
of myself you know i used to speak i'd
go
i'd speak to hundreds of people a day
you know get up and just tell my story
and
i might have a drink before i go in
there just because i wanted to relax
you know a little bit and then
afterwards i'd go drink
a bunch and i had a driver you know i
didn't
i had my own driver and stuff so i
didn't need
i wasn't drinking and driving so uh
that became a little bit worse and a
little bit worse and it was always
tequila that was my thing
and after a couple years of that things
things started happening that weren't
cool it wasn't
any kind of crime or any kind of
anything really bad it was just like my
behavior wasn't what it should have been
and then the incident happened in 2013
with the cops
which was actually a bipolar meltdown do
you know that took place after about a
month of not drinking
but the drinking is what led to it led
up to this whole thing i
quit drinking but then i started having
all this resentment in my mind
another terrible thing to have in your
life is resentment right
so uh i was having some bad thoughts
and i didn't get depressed but instead i
be i started
discovering this other part of myself
that's this manic
side and i was going up this
hill of mania and i didn't realize it
uh i just thought i was thinking really
good
but i wasn't so that led to the moment
with the cops
that was very unfortunate in some ways
but
the way i look at is everything that
happens happens
because you did that you made it happen
one way or the other
yeah it shouldn't have happened the way
that it happened but
you know i'm the one who creates my life
so now i'm still on uh restrictions from
that
but i had this
you know the art was of the african art
was
i i realized a way for me to forget
about all that and that's
it's been a good thing in that sense hey
dave i lost a friend of mine years ago
i never forget the day when it happened
uh it was an o5 when i got the phone
call i was on my way to an event at
diamondbar
california and it was a buddy of mine
who had a hard time with the
drugs he started off with weed and then
it led to a lot of different things and
eventually the hardest one he couldn't
get off of was
vicodin it was 25 to 50 a day and i
would take him to the rehab center and
eventually at the
very young age he passed away what which
if you i mean i don't know how much you
uh uh uh you
you know messed around with drugs and
how much you tried for yourself
which one of them was the one that was
the toughest to get off of where
it got a hold of you was there anyone
that got you the worst
well it's different there's different
errors in my life
so uh the the first drug that
appealed to me and made me go oh wow
life is worth living
you know because i tried all kinds of
drugs but it wasn't until
i did methamphetamine and i put it in my
arm
uh the very first time
and i i just my it was it was my first
epiphany you know i told you about the
epiphany that changed my life later
well this was like a this was a
drug-induced
epiphany and i looked around and i
started
i became a different person you know not
a good person
not a good person but uh i was enjoying
my life for the first time and uh
so i was i was doing the dope so
it was hard to get off of that in this
it was a psychological
thing you know i i didn't want to live
without it because without it i wasn't
happy
but drugs physically
physically like vicodin is horrible if
you gotta
if you do a lot of bikini i did get
hooked on oxycontin at one point
and the physical withdrawal from that is
something you do not want to live you
know live with if you're doing a lot of
it
oxycontin yeah i think it's similar to
it i mean
virginia could be the same thing you
know
yeah it's it's uh it's uh you know it's
it's funny when it gets a hold of you
it's like you can't even recognize
i remember one time i'm at a restaurant
with this guy and he said i got to go to
my car to get something i'm like no
you're not you don't need you're not
going to your car to get something i
follow him i didn't trust what he was
saying
i follow him to the car he goes to his
trunk he opens it up
opens up the thing picks up like six
seven to throw tonight grabbed his hand
grabbed the bottle
walked off he's crying begging me to
allow him to take six pills
begging me begging me say please let me
say i'm not gonna give it to you i'm
begging you i'm in so much pain
i've never seen any grown man
in that kind of pain i got to take this
guy to somewhere and even after the 14
days of rehab the guy that was selling
the vicodin
was a former dentist who was selling it
to a guy that
a dentist was getting the vicodin off to
this kid who was a
anyways it's a whole different story but
man it's great to see what you've done
with yourself by the way since you have
the experience dave any
any opinions you have because you know
the prison reform conversation comes up
all the time right so
you have those who uh uh
say hey you know why are you sending
people to jail like i think you went to
jail for
stealing cell a 12.99 and i think you
did a year for that is is that true or
is that fake story
i did i did two years for that one they
turned it into a
robbery it was really just a shoplifting
but i resisted the rest on the way out
and uh they because of my record see
that's just that's a lesson in itself i
had already done time
i've been in prison twice at that point
and
one of them was in massachusetts for
armed robbery
so i came back and this happened
and because of my record they charged me
with robbery they would have otherwise
not done that
and then i couldn't i even went to trial
on it and did time over
so no no no i guess where i was going
with i just asked if it's true and i
think you said something very
interesting at the time you said i
really suck at crime
my heart's not in it yeah but the point
was
but the question i was going to ask you
was the following do you agree with the
consensus or
when people say why do you let people go
into jail for
petty crime because it's a training
ground for doing the bigger crimes when
you went to jail
were you around other people that taught
you was it a training type of a ground
to
teach someone to come out and do the
bigger crime or no you don't agree with
that
for me it was uh i guess
maybe some people hit a bottom when they
first go to prison and they don't go
back
they don't they don't keep doing it and
that's great when that happens
for me um because of all my
issues whether dope was the only way you
know methamphetamine was the only way i
could feel good
i had to keep doing it and try to figure
out ways to
continue this lifestyle and then and so
for to me it was a trading ground
it was but what i was getting trained to
do was
something stupider the next time you
know that's that's the way i look at
that
some guys are just really good criminals
and some guys like me
i never really wanted to be a criminal i
just
didn't have much of a choice i guess
did you did you uh uh see the
challenges with a lot of your either
peers when you were in
or when you started hiring folks that
there was
help that was needed through a doctor
medication
because you know some people you'll have
different opinions on that some will say
it's just an excuse some will say no
they need help like there's a debate
that goes back and forth
from your experiences from where you
were at have you seen some that use an
excuse
or have you seen it where a lot of them
do have something that they're
struggling with from childhood maybe for
you was your father maybe for
somebody else abused you know somebody
died did you see some mental link to
the the treachery or the the mistakes
they made and when it come down to
committing a crime was there a link
between the two
yeah i think everything has
has a you know a cause and
an effect so uh i think a lot of things
can be scientifically very not
they can be brought down to
accountability like you're saying if
um in my case learning to be
self-accountable was a huge part of my
of my growth so when i look at say
the homeless problem uh in portland for
example
i i'm like okay the reason
this is happening is because it's too
easy to be homeless
you make it you make it easy you make it
if
if life if like i've been homeless
before back in the day right
on the streets of detroit michigan and
they weren't it wasn't good it was
winter time and i did not want to be
homeless
i did everything i could because i was
trying to survive out there
these guys it's they're like
okay well you've got a problem you're
homeless so you know after a while they
just
become it becomes another uh
part of the city another place to live
it's all over the streets
um and i'm like this is being enabled
so it's enablement of uh in this case
homelessness
homelessness which is it also enables
drug addiction
uh you can say well i can give
treatment to that person you know and
that's gonna say well
not really it on its own it's not going
to do it because
they can just go right back really easy
and and start that
that cycle right all over again and they
will
so to me the first thing that has to be
done with
just stop crime and violence and
you know drug addiction and and
homelessness
is you got to have tough love and
because i would have never changed if i
had a life an easy life
and to move forward so that
i don't like excuses i don't i don't put
up with excuses
not from myself or anyone else what a
way of explaining it
and do you have any other thoughts on
prison reform like i'm sure what the
conversation comes up do you say
you know if let's just say they hired
you and you got a call from the white
house saying hey you know we have a
handful of people that want to bring in
to give us their perspective of how they
change their lives like you're one of
the best stories in america
you change your life what other feedback
would you give
for us to both minimize crime as well as
not to create a good training ground
would you have any other feedback on
prison reform
well uh what i just said
kind of uh encompasses the whole
the whole thing so that's my my deal i
do believe
that you can't you can't have it doesn't
help to
hate on people it doesn't help to
it any kind of negativity is bad
encouraging positive behavior is good
uh but also holding having the character
stick
you know kind of worse than everything
in life
so you're if i can
if i can help you you got to help
yourself if you can help yourself i can
help you
but if you're not going to do your part
then what am i doing
you know so i i don't have like
specifics i uh you know like one
specific principle or
uh this is just my experience and i look
around and i
see the things that i disagree with and
uh and i just go to me it's common sense
you just can't make it that easy what a
story by the way uh
just out of curiosity who who do people
say you look like i have three people
i'm curious to know if i have any one of
them right who do people say you look
like
i'm looking at myself right now and i'm
going i have no idea
[Laughter]
so but you don't have one person by the
way they look like me
they look like me so i'm going to give
you a couple more i don't know
well first of all you look like a
hollywood star i mean if people see your
pictures
you look like you belong in hollywood
you don't look like you belong in
you know selling uh bread you look like
a hollywood star yourself
i i see a couple of your younger
pictures you look like a patrick swayze
meets kurt russell meets a
robin williams that's kind of how i see
him oh wow
that's good i've i've heard the robin
williams things
growing up when he was mort and i was
about uh
14 or something and ladies women would
always say oh yeah
and you cute little robin williams you
know i don't really like that
i have so much respect for you dave and
i hope this message is shared with the
right people where you could help
inspire millions of people out there
once again appreciate you for being a
guest on valuetainment
thank you i i do appreciate your
questions your line of questions i think
they were really good questions
uh i've done a lot of interviews and
this has really been one of the one of
the best ones
thank you dave appreciate you what a
comeback story huh can you imagine like
you go from doing
jail time for 15 years and then you have
an epiphany moment you come out
you come out with this bread called
dave's killer bread and you go from
selling 200
loaves a week to now they're selling
nearly 10 million a week can you imagine
that
sells it for 275 million dollars biggest
takeaway i'm curious comment below
if you enjoyed this interview got
another interview i think you'll enjoy
with freeway rick ross the original
freeway red cross if you've never
watched it
click over here to watch thank you
everybody bye-bye